[Music]
lactose-free
this is a comment tag which has
foundered many food packets these days
lactose as we know is a natural sugar
found in milk but why should we get rid
of lactose that's because many people
have a peculiar intolerance towards this
natural sugar
however lactose free products but not an
option until a few years back it's all
possible now due to the advancements in
the field of biotechnology that useful
products like lactose free consumables
and many more can be produced so what
exactly is biotechnology well it's
defined as the utilization of organisms
or a part of the organism or any
biological process for the benefit of
mankind for example we know how bread is
made the dough is added with the
organisms like yeast which help in
releasing certain chemicals the
reactions ultimately give us the soft
and fluffy loaf on baking here we've
used yeast organism to obtain the
product of our interest
so do we mean that bread making is a
part of biotechnology well kind of
processes like fermentation are
considered as a part of classical
biotechnology as they include the
utilization of organisms thus obtaining
products for human benefit like food
items medicines hybrid crops and so on
are all possible due to biotechnology
does there are numerous applications of
biotechnology now let's have a look at a
few examples to understand how wide the
field is let's also understand how an
organism or a part of it or some
processes can be used to harvest
important products for mankind
let's take examples of white production
hepatitis B vaccine synthesis and Golden
Rice production let's have a look at
each individually
now wine is usually made from the grapes
how can grapes which are fruits get
converted to a beverage like wine well
this is where the micro organism named
yeast comes into play it feeds on the
sugars present in the grape juice and
releases alcohol and carbon dioxide as
byproducts here a complete organism is
used for the processing of grape juice
and to convert it into wine this was the
first part of the definition the second
part of the definition states that a
part of the organism can be used so how
can that be done for this let's have a
look at the application of biotechnology
in the field of medicine well the
emergence of biotechnology has been
nothing less than a boon for the medical
industry everything ranging from
vaccines to gene therapy has raised the
standards of healthy living now let's
take hepatitis B vaccine as an example
this vaccine has a recombinant version
previously hepatitis B vaccine was
developed from the blood of the humans
who were already suffering from
hepatitis B but this was very painful
for the patients as the amount of blood
required for vaccine production was too
high so extracting some particular
amount of blood of the infected person
was very excruciating and as the vaccine
was derived directly from the patient's
body there could be negative reactions
in the receiving candidate with the
development of biotechnology newer
vaccines that are synthetic in nature
started getting produced on the similar
lines the commercially available
hepatitis B vaccine is now being
synthetically made by utilizing a small
part of the pathogenic virus it's also
known as recombinant hepatitis B vaccine
and studies have shown that getting
infected with hepatitis B is nearly
impossible
if a person is injected with recombinant
hepatitis B vaccine isn't this a miracle
it is equivalent this is also known as
the first anti-cancer vaccine and why so
because it's proven that the vaccine
helps in reducing the chances of
developing liver cancer this is one
example of how apart from any organism
can be used for product development
now that we've glanced at the two
examples of application of the
biotechnology let's move ahead to the
third one the last part of the
definition stated the use of a process
let's take the Golden Rice as a third
example is the rice made of gold
no absolutely not then why is it called
Golden Rice well the rice we usually see
is whitish in color
however the golden rice we're talking
about is a modified version which is
yellowish in color hence the name golden
rice but what makes this rice yellowish
and so important it's the presence of
beta-carotene in the rice and what is
that beta-carotene is a red orange
colored pigment which gets converted to
vitamin A in the human body we all know
the importance of this vitamin it is
most essential for the development and
maintenance of good vision the
deficiency of vitamin A causes vision
related issues and malnutrition
any idea why was only rice chosen for
modification that was because the staple
diet for a majority of the population in
the areas affected with vitamin A
deficiency was rice so to minimize the
deficiency this variety of rice was
developed the modification of rice was
done by exploiting a biological process
making it a classic example of
biotechnological achievements this
variety of rice falls under the category
of genetically modified organisms
abbreviated as GMOs and what exactly are
these G
most do watch our upcoming videos to
find that out till then subscribe to our
channel for some more amazing videos on
biotechnology happy learning